ich bin gestern über dieses video
gestolpert und zwar erklärte da diese
youtube während wie viel kohle sie mit
ihrem eine million klick video verdient
hat und dass ich mir nicht mehr oben
ohne großen hauptrolle typen und musiker
und wochen sondern habe ich mich dann
auch gefragt ob die flammen in meine
beiden videos die über zwei millionen
klicks haben weil das ist natürlich von
youtube die youtuber anders ist ein land
zu land anders ich mir angeguckt und
leute ich kann nur eins sagen dass wir
sie mit ihrem eine million klicks video
verdient hat ist sowas von dermaßen weit
davon entfernt von dem was ich mit
meinem 2 millionen blick video verdient
hat es ist jetzt 2009/10 und das ist
immer noch ein thema über das youtuber
einfach selten reden und genau wie die
störche habe ich auch meine community
denken dass man mit 2 02 minuten klick
wieder verdient einfach was mich
interessiert was ihr denkt was dabei so
rum kommen kann das bei instagram
rumgekommen ist es sehr sehr breit
gefächert zum beispiel hier einmal
10.000 hier einmal 2000 jahren als
20.000 aber 50.000 und der top schreibt
wenn es nicht gut läuft 2000 euro und ob
es bei meinen beiden zwei millionen
beziehungsweise 2,4 millionen klick
videos gut gelaufen ist punkten und
selbst einem youtube-video peter das ist
übrigens neues youtube sowie was mich
übel abhaken
das fragt jeden allerdings überweist
alter einfach viel übersichtlich war
egal da drin steht alles mögliche von
abonnentenzahl hier leute es ist einfach
lächerlich macht jetzt einmal die
200.000 voll ich heule jede nacht mit in
den schlaf
wir sind zum beispiel statistiken für
einen meiner letzten videos dass sie
waren jetzt genau wie quasi von tag zu
tag die klicks da gestiegen sind hier
haben wir den stark war quasi tagsüber
hier wenn so ein kleines plateau ist es
war einfach nachts ist klar und bei
frisch hochgeladenen video sieht man
hier auch schon eine kleine prognose wie
sich die videos dann entwickeln ob die
klicks dann besser laufen als gewöhnlich
oder schlechter und nicht nur sie wann
hier wie viele klicks zu bekommen hat
sondern auch wie viele abonnenten man
durch das video bekommen hat und eben
auch wie viel cash man durch das video
bekommen hat und bei dem video ist es
ganz klischeehaft ungefährdeten euro pro
1000 klicks ungefähr 99 euro durch das
video auf 300.000 klicks was eigentlich
genau das ist klischee bestätigen würde
ungefähr 1000 klicks ist gleich ein euro
in der regel gibt es eigentlich immer
zwei arten die sich videos verhalten
entweder ist es geht am anfang direkt
komplett stall durch die decke und
flacht daneben überzeugte aus oder es
läuft am anfang ein bisschen okay dann
steigt an was mir die höhe und läuft
danach irgendwann zu außen stagnieren
bisschen komplett anders werde es bei
allem meiner videos und zwar beim einer
sex tape parodie auf die gute katja hier
sieht man am anfang was ziemlich geil
direkt an 25.000 erste kriegt hier
direkt 60.000 vielleicht sogar die ganze
zeit noch echt viel ging echt stark das
ist dann halt am ende auch um die
stadien hat und danach sage und schreibe
drei monaten einfach nochmal komplett
warum auch immer auf 100.000 klicks pro
tag drauf geschossen
also ich habe innerhalb von fünf tagen
nochmals irgendwie 400.000 klicks sowie
den kopf gekriegt weswegen auch das
video jetzt übrigens absolut geile
anderthalb millionen klicks gekriegt hat
was absolut geil ist auf der einen seite
also wirklich als dieser zwei tpk man
sich noch mehr leute ist wieder geguckt
habe dachte ich wirklich unerlässlich
dass jetzt wirklich jeder anschauen weil
der queen zwei mal wieder stark dabei ok
jetzt aber ohne umwege zu meinen beiden
krassesten videos und zwar war das
einmal hier ganz allem ein oldtimer
classic ich gehe heimlich an revis pc
und gebe alles eine liebes aus mit
aktuell 2,4 millionen klicks das video
wurde sich 8,5 millionen minuten lang
angeguckt das ist so dämlich dass man
sich überlegt dass man einfach wir
rechnen mal kurz nach 140000 stunden
5800 tage
also insgesamt wurde sich dieses video
von leuten 16 jahre angeguckt auf jeden
fall 36,5 tausend abonnenten alleine
durch dieses video und bei diesem video
war es eben auch so dass es einfach von
null auf hundert komplett kalt kann in
die höhe geschossen hat am ersten tag
114000 zweiten dann 300.000 da noch mal
300.000 und dann noch mal 200.000 oben
drauf und dann am ende eben auch
abgeflacht ist so wie es mit allen
videos ist und wir glaube ich jetzt mit
diesem video mit 2,4 millionen klicks
verdient wir erinnern uns bei der cp m
von vorhin die ungefähr 1,1 euro pro
1000 klicks war wenn wir bei ungefähr
2600 euro in aller jetzt wird auf jeden
fall schmecken ja aber was dachten sich
youtube götter perfekt alter ja auf
jeden fall ein saftiges drittel davon
ich weiß auch nicht genau woran es liegt
meine cpm war als ich angefangen habe
youtube richtig richtig schlecht einfach
vielleicht weil ich in dem video ein
paar mal geflucht haben und aufregendere
geflucht hat und ich zensiert habe aber
es war mir auch irgendwie egal auf jeden
fall generell auch meine videos häufig
haben echt relativ geringe tpm auch wenn
es mittlerweile viele care ist aber hier
zb 700 euro für 2,4 millionen klicks ist
halt echt nicht viel
also wirklichkeit gar nicht viel das
sieht aber deutlich besser aus bei dem
anderen video mit 2,4 millionen dass ich
mit standards gemacht hat und zwar haben
wir 2,4 millionen klicks und 1300 euro
sc greven you was immer noch recht wenig
ist das ist der cp m von 50 cent das
halt wirklich michael schlecht ist also
aber natürlich trotzdem besser als 700
euro von dem refrain krank bin und war
ich davor auch nicht auf die youtube
klicks angewiesen weil da wäre es auf
jeden fall richtig schwierig gewesen
damit zu essen und zu trinken wenn ihr
euch jetzt fragt wie kann die
behinderungen denn davon leben
ich habe zum beispiel der schnittkurs
gemacht wo ich euch die schneiden
beibringe denn haben sich einige leute
gekauft und er so richtig richtig geil
und ich werde euch der kurs bringt euch
wirklich viel da gibt es nämlich aktuell
mit dem tutorial wieder 95 prozent
rabatt nur übers wochenende und wenn ihr
lust auf meinen eigenen absolut leisten
und hast den waffen in da geht dann
steigt man das ist gold ab da werdet ihr
auch laufen gehalten wann der service
startet und so weiter und so fort und
möchtet ihr mich auf meiner reise
begleiten
so könnt ihr diesen kanal abonnieren und
sehen wir uns mal wieder ganz gut für
sie
[Musik]